and if I like he's showing all the right  signs like good communication skills  like he's showing me that he's like he  wants me yeah I would definitely have a  conversation and in that conversation I  would gauge what kind of man he is is he  asking like and he feels uncomfortable  for x y and some of those reasons to me  wouldn't be valid but some of them and I  think like a a certain man could show me  and I'd be like you know what maybe  that's not the best idea if we were  dating and a man's uncomfortable then  I'm absolutely gonna listen last  question but I'm not going to if that  becomes a habit that every time I want  to go out my friends you're like no stay  in I don't like a headache to a guy I  have a girl that doesn't listen and he  has to argue with every time he asks her  to do something but